unser bild reporter björn strietzel ist
seit tagen in der ukraine an der front
und sieht das leid das der krieg
anrichtet
hier donnern die granaten den minuten
takt immer wieder anschläge raketen
explosionen artillerie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
front besuch in der süd ukraine überall
im land staub und zerstörung den krieg
spürt man hier an den unheilbar namen
einer landschaft entlang bild-reporter
bian strietzel begleitet eine einheit
der mörsergranaten wir fahren im auto
wir fahren schnell es ist nicht sicher
ohne eine abdeckung zu fahren es gibt
kein tempolimit im krieg jeden moment
könnten raketen auf unsere position
geschossen werden wir sollen
schnellstmöglichst die straße verlassen
in einem dorf nahe denn jetzt zeigt uns
soldat ladislav seine mörser raketen
stellung er ist aufgeregt denn diese
neuen moerser haben eine unvorstellbare
durchschlagskraft kaliber 82 millimeter
nicht die größten aber ausreichend
die front ist ganz nah acht kilometer
von hier ist der feind wir können sie
mit unseren neuen moerser nicht ganz
erreichen aber mit den alten wäre es
unmöglich gewesen
sie sind nicht schlecht sicher aber
nicht so durchschlagend wie die 120er in
unserer stellung schätzen wir die lage
ein schützen unsere truppen vor
bewegungen vor russischen angriffen
wladislaw kommt aus sabrina er vermisst
seine familie
er zeigt uns sehr stolz sein handy video
von seinem letzten einsatz
nach einer kurzen pause müssen wir
weiter immer weiter nie lange verweilen
wir gehen am rand einer landstraße zu
einem nahe liegenden dorf wladislaw
läuft zu unserer sicherheit 50 meter vor
uns
seine einheit ist in bruchbuden
ähnlichen baracken positioniert es
scheint alles stabil zu sein und
plötzlich raketen einschlagen wir müssen
uns verstecken fliehen zu einem keller
und suchen schutz durch die attacke hört
mich auf
[Musik]
wir bleiben in dem keller für mehrere
stunden die soldaten erzählen uns es
wurden mehrere raketen geschossen die
letzten sechs näher und näher
für wladislaw von seine truppe
gewöhnlich seit jahren ist für sie der
krieg alltag geworden diese soldaten
müssen mit einem offenen auge schlafen
sie wissen nicht wann sie ihre familien
wieder umarmen können oder wann sie die
nächste rakete putins trifft nur eines
ist gewiss der krieg geht weiter
[Musik]